[موسيقى]
ايها المارون بين الكلمات العابره احملوا
اسماءكم وانصرفوا واسحبوا ساعاتكم من
وقتنا وانصرفوا وخذوا ما شئتم من زرقه
البحر ورمل الذاكره وخذوا ما شئتم من صور
كي تعرف انكم لن تعرفوا ابيات من قصيده
عابرون في كلام عابر للشاعر الفلسطيني
محمود درويش وهي واحده من قصائد عديده
تفاعل فيها الشاعر الراحل مع نضال الشعب
الفلسطيني مؤكدا في كلماته العابره
للازمان والاجيال على هويته العربيه وحقه
في المقاومه كلام عابر قيل قبل 35 عاما في
قصيدته بعيده تفجر الانتفاضه الفلسطينيه
الاولى انتفاضه الحجاره لكن لم تمحو
السنون صداها المرحب عربيا والغاضب بل
والهيسيري اسرائيليا كما وصفه درويش نفسه
وقد حركت ضده دعوه قضائيه في باريس بتهمه
اثاره الكراهيه رحل درويش وبقيت اعماله هو
وغيره من مبدعين ومثقفين فلسطينيين وعرب
شاهد على مواكبه الفنون كافه مراحل النضال
منذ النكبه حامله مشروعا مقاوما يؤكد
الحقوق الفلسطينيه وينافح عنها من ينسى
حنظله ورسول مناجي العلي وقد حققت كثير من
اعمال المبدعين الفلسطينيين انتشارا
عالميا يقول الناقد الادبي حميد دباشي ان
القضيه الفلسطينيه لم تعد قضيه
الفلسطينيين لوحدهم وتمكن الفن من ايصالها
الى العالم كله وبات الجميع معنيا
بانتصارها في نهايه المطاف في قصتنا الفن
الفلسطيني المقاوم نحاول تلمس تفاعلي كافه
الفنون الفلسطينيه مع العمل الثوري
للحركات الوطنيه وكيف ساهمت في تعريف
العالم بها من خلال تجارب لفنانين
فلسطينيين في الوطن وفي الشتات نستكمل
بقيه هذه القصه مع ضيوفنا دلال ابو امنه
الفنانه والدكتوره في علوم الدماغ
والاعصاب والدكتور بشار شموط المتخصص في
مجال الارشبه الرقميه للارث المرئي
والمسموع الفلسطيني واميه جحا رسامه
الكاريكاتير نسال ضيوفنا عن اهميه الفن
كاداه للمقاومه وكيفيه تطور الفنون
الفلسطينيه رغم الضغوط والقيود والى اي حد
استفادت من التراث الفلسطيني والتجارب
الفنيه العالميه وما مدى نجاحها في جذب
اهتمام شعوب العالم للقضيه الفلسطينيه لكن
بدايه لنشاهد القصه وبعدها الحوار
[موسيقى]
هذا المكان مثل غيره من الامكنه في فلسطين
هي كانت كفيله بانها تطلع اشخاص اللي هم
قادرين يعبروا عن ذواتهم
هو هذا الفنان المقاوم اللي بتوصفه الناس
هو طلع من هون من عند هاي الجوزه وهاي
الرمانه وهذه الزيتونه اللي من اول من
خلقت
[موسيقى]
ومثابته
الله يعطيها الصحه والعمر
ان شاء الله
الحين بوشوش
كلش
عن حياه
الفلاحين من ابوي ومن سيدي وسته في الداخل
في عرعره كله اعزز عندي مش عارف يعني بديش
احكي كثير فلسفه بس يعني في انتماء حقيقي
للمكان يعني انا بحب اشتغل يعني مش انه
ابوي جابرني اجي اشتغل معه انا بستمت
فبفكر انه ضروري ضروري يكون الفنان جزء من
المكان اللي بحكي عنه
[موسيقى]
شطي البح
هذا العثمانيه طبعا
انا بالاغاني بحاول ارسم الخارطه
الثقافيه تاعت فلسطين ما قبل النكبه شو
كانوا يغنوا الناس كيف كانوا عايشين لانها
بتوصف كيف الناس كانوا عايشين يعني السامر
بتحكي عن الحكم
التراويد بتحكي عن وداع العروس والى اخره
اغاني العمل القطاف الزيتون بتحكي عن حياه
المزارع انا بحاول اصور هذا العالم
الثقافي تبع فلسطين بس احنا بحاجه كمان
نجمع معلومات كيف كان شكل فلسطين على ارض
الواقع كمان جغرافيا تاريخيا وثقافيا
[موسيقى]
فداك يا فدائي يا خالي نقش الفن الفلسطيني
منذ النكبه فعلا مقاوما وكب كافه مراحل
النضال ومع انطلاق الفصائل الفلسطينيه
والكفاح المسلح ادركت منظمه التحرير وكافه
الفصائل الدوره المهمه للفنون بالنسبه
لمشروع التحرر الفلسطيني
وفي اطار الاعلام الموحد لمنظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه ظهرت وحده افلام فلسطين
وسطعت تجربه الفرقه المركزيه وماتبعها من
تجارب غنائيه مهمه كما تم تاسيس قسم
الثقافه الفنيه الذي تولى ادارته اسماعيل
شموط وتمام الاكحل
[موسيقى]
هد عسكر الغدار
بالسيف الفرد الموزر
عددهم موثور الله
يجعل
حيث عن الجيش اصبحت رمز لنضال ضد البريطان
ضد الاحتلال البريطاني بارض فلسطين حسنه
وعبيشه حسنه بتحبي غبيشه وعم تعطيه عمليا
تقدير حالنا شو عم بصير معه عم بتقول له
انتبه الجيش جاي حتى يعتقلك وعم تحكيلو
كمان شو وضع العائله هل العائله ما زالت
عائلته متمسكه فيه ولا في احتمال انني
تخلوا عنه
طبعا في تجارب كانت جدا بارزه اللي كلنا
نتغنى فيها الاغاني اللي رافقت مرحله
العاصفه انا يا اخي والى اخره اغاني
العاشقين تجربه ابو عرب تجربه الفن الشعبي
مركز الفن الشعبي فرقه الفنون الشعبيه
الفلسطينيه
تجربه صابرين وجورج قرمز طبعا التجارب
ايضا اللي لم تكن لم تنشا داخل فلسطين
[موسيقى]
بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه في الخمسينيات
والستينيات في السويد كان كل شيء مناصرا
لاسرائيل وكان هناك تركيز كبير على
اسرائيل ويبدو ان الاعلام نسي كل شيء
يتعلق بالفلسطينيين والماساه التي حلت بهم
لكن جورج واخيه جاء الى غوتنبرغ اضافه الى
بعض الفلسطينيين الاخرين جاءوا ايضا الى
جوتنبرغ وتعلمت الكثير منهم حول ذلك
[موسيقى]
فكره الكوفيه هي فكره لغه تفاهم بيننا
وبين الشعب السويدي يعني جماعتنا لما
كانوا يلقي الكلمه ما يجي خمسه سته اشخاص
لكن لما كنت امسك العود واغني يجي ميه
ويسقفوا لي ومبسوطين طب انا لقيت انه بقدر
افهم الناس قضيتي والناس مبسوطه وفرحانه
من الصغير للكبير الكل بيجي يسمعنا
وبلشنا 1972 يعني من مده طويله ونكتب قصص
ونحكي للناس قصتنا يعني اغاني مش مكتوبه
لالنا للعرب يعني مكتوبه انه للسويد
نفهمهن شو حصل معنا كشعب فلسطين
لم تقتصر السرديه الفنيه الفلسطينيه على
الغناء بل تجاوزتها الى غالبيه الفنون
الاخرى اذ ظهر جيل من الفنانين التشكيليين
منذ خمسينيات وستينيات القرن المنصرم
استخدموا تعابير بصريه لاعاده صياغه
الخطاب السياسي امثال اسماعيل شموط ومصطفى
الحلاج وسليمان منصور وعبد الحي مسلم
وتمام الاكحل
وقد تنوعت الفنون التشكيليه الفلسطينيه
التي اشتبكت مع الاحتلال وصولا الى فنون
الشارع التي جعلت جدرانها معرضا للفنانين
والمقاومين في كافه هباتهم وانتفاضاتهم
انا بشوف انه فن الشارع هو فن خارج عن
النص فبتلاقي انه من بدايات الانتفاضه
الاولى بلشوا اللي هو فن الشارع فهو كان
عباره عن
طريقه لتوصيل رساله المقاوم للمشاهد او
للقارئ او للباحث
او للمحتل
على الرغم من قله الافلام الفلسطينيه طوال
تاريخها الحديث الا ان تتبع بدايات
السينما الفلسطينيه يمكن العوده به الى
عهد الانتداب البريطاني ولعل المرحله
الابرز التي ارتبطت بها عدسه الكاميرا
بفوهه البندقيه كانت مع بدايه مقاومه
التنظيمات الفلسطينيه منذ منتصف الستينيات
لتمتد بعدها الى يومنا هذا وقد نجحت
مجموعه من الافلام بحصد جوائز عالميه
متجاوزه كافه العراقيل التي تلاحق الاعمال
الفلسطينيه مثل فيلم 200 متر للمخرج امين
نايفه فيلم
هو فيلم الروائي الطويل الاول
وفكرته نابعه كمان من تجربتي الشخصيه طبعا
وهي مش قصتي انا يعني هي قصه الاف
العائلات في فلسطين اللي هو باختصار القسط
الفيلم هي عائله تفرقت بسبب الجدار الاب
من الضفه الغربيه بحمل الهويه الفلسطينيه
وزوجته واولاده عايشين في الجهه الاخرى
فهو هون هم هون وبينهم 200 متر
فما بقدرش يكون عندهم
اللي بصير انه ابنه بيدخل المستشفى في
الجهه الاخرى من الجدار ولا بصير بده يروح
عند ابنه على المستشفى يعني هاي يعني حاجه
انسانيه حق في الحركه فاحنا بنروح مع الاب
في رحلته للوصول للمستشفى بالتهريب
بالمخاطر يعني عبر الحواجز الاحتلال
[موسيقى]
يعني مغلق يذهب الى بيتك هاي كانت تنحكى
لنا واحنا على المعبر انه حتى هاي الورقه
مش كافيه انك تدخل لعند اهلك يعني كما
تصريح زياره لدار سيدي كان بالمستشفى
فالحارس او المناوب ما بده يدخلنا لحد ما
اخوي يصيح عليه وحكى معه بالانجليزي حكى
له ماي جراند
سيدي مات
فطلعت عليه بفكر انه بمزح يعني انه بلعب
لعبه عليه عشان يدخلنا يعني ولا طلع عن جد
احنا رايحين على الجنازه
ما بعرفش ما بعرف
[موسيقى]
طواله اكثر من خمسه وسبعين عاما حاول
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اخضاع الفن الفلسطيني
وتفريغه من دوره الوطني من خلال مجموعه من
الاجراءات التي كانت تمس المنتج الفنيه
احيانا او الفنانه نفسه في احيان اخرى
فاوقف واعتقل فنانين بتهمه التحريض من
خلال ما يقدمونه من مشاريع فنيه
مثل ما حصل مع الفنان مصطفى الكرد الذي
اعتقلته سلطات الاحتلال بسبب عمل مسرحي
والفنان فتحي غب الذي تم اعتقاله بسبب
لوحاته المحرضه على الاحتلال وقد وصل
الحال في اسكات اصوات واقلام الفنانين
الفلسطينيين الى تصفيتهم الجسديه كما حدث
مع ناجي العلي وغسان كنفاني
انا لليوم بستنى من الجمارك الاسرائيليه
بدها تحرر لي عشرين عمل فني انتجتهم في
باريس
ارسلتم عن طريق الدي اتش ال
واعتقلتهم الجمارك او وقفتهم لحديت ما انا
ادفع مبالغ هائله انا لا املكها اصلا ثمن
هاي اللوحات
الاحتلال طبعا اذا بكون في سيارتي اكثر من
علبه سبراي ممكن يوقفوني ويقعدوا يسالوني
يكون في مسائلات ليش وكيف وكذا
[موسيقى]
انمي حصان على
شو بده يصير
مش غريب على الاحتلال الصهيوني الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
مضايقه الفنانين ودائما بستذكر وخوف
الغزاه من الاغنيات مش بس من الاغنيات من
اللوحات من الرسمات من الشعر من القصائد
بالانتفاضه الثانيه على سبيل المثال اللي
كان يضبط مع
كاسيتات حتى مش بالضبط كان سيديهات
بكاسيتات وبذكر الاستاذ سهيل خوري ضبطته
بسيارته كاسيتات غنائيه طبعا ثوريه وتم
اعتقاله الفنون الشعبيه فرقه الفنون
الشعبيه كمان عندها قصه قصص
مع هذا الموضوع مع هاي المضايقات
بالسابق عشان هيك كنا نشوف بالسابق انه
كان يتم انتاج اغاني او يتم انتاج لوحات
موسيقيه بدون ذكر اسماء المغنين كنت
تتحزري هذا الصوت وين انا سمعته من قبل
[موسيقى]
احنا تعرضنا بعد واحد من من العروض في
فلسطين 48 تعرضنا لتحديدات بالقتل
واطلقوا علينا اسماء الارهابيين لانه كيف
يعني منحبل الاعلام الفلسطينيه بمنطقه هني
يعتبروها منطقه اسرائيليه بالنسبه لنا هذا
عمقنا الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
الحكومه السعوديه متهمتنا احنا من عهد
الساميه لانه بخافوا من الاعلام لانه اذا
الاعلام صار سلبي ضدهم معناته السويد متى
توقف ضدهن معناته
صار عندهم
عايشين على الاعلام
لم يكن النشاط الفلسطيني الفني خارج
فلسطين بمعزل عن المضايقات اذ كانت تهمه
معاداه الساميه حاضره دائما لتقييد كافه
الانشطه الثقافيه الفلسطينيه حول العالم
ومن حالات الحظر التي تعرض لها الفن
الفلسطيني في الخارج رفض اليونسكو في عام
2015 لضم مشروع ارشيف ملصق فلسطين الى
قائمه اليونسكو للتراث العالمي بذريعه
انها هجوميه وغير مقبوله
كما تعرضت فرقه كوفيه ومؤسسها جورج توتري
في السويد للمنع والايقاف في عام 2019
بتهمه معاداه الساميه بعد ترديد اغنيتهم
تعيش فلسطين في تظاهرات اقامتها جمعيه
الشباب الديمقراطيين في السويد بمناسبه
عيد العمال بحجه ان كلمات الاغنيه تدعو
لسحق الصهيونيه
اذا الاغنيه بتهدد شعب كامل معناته لازم
كلنا نعرف شو اهميه الكلمه والاغنيه في
مواجهه هذا المحتل والس
[موسيقى]
ابع
اهم شيء الاثر
يعني بكون جمهور له بصير هذا الجمهور
يستنى فيه متى تقي بده يرسم رسمه عن
الحاله كذا يعني انا لقيت رسائل اكثر من
مره
انه تقييم متى بدك ترسم عن الشهيد فلان او
متى بدك ترسم عن هذا الاشي
فبصفي الفنان تحت يعني طائله المسؤوليه
الجائزه تحديدا او الجوائز الى روح سته
انحرمت منها بسبب الجدار لما الفيلم بلش
يلف العالم وبلش يروح مهرجانات واشوف رده
فعل الناس مش عارف اعبر يعني الاكل الكلمه
المعبره عن جد بس انه يعني كميه الرضا على
التعب التابته اني اشوف هاي النتيجه اشي
مذهل للامانه في احد المهرجانات في مهرجان
الجونه
في ناس بس خلصت الفيلم دخلوا
مع انه النهايه مش مش يعني مش نهايه دم
ولا قتل ولا حدا بموت بس هاي الرحله اللي
هم عاشوها مع هاي الاسره
وحسوا في الناس كيف عايشه يعني كميه الناس
شفتها اللي بتعيط واللي بتبكي كانت اللي
تاثرت عن جد يعني
[موسيقى]
الفكره انه وحده من اهم الادعاءات الكاذبه
اتجاه شعبنا الفلسطيني انه احنا جينا جاء
المحتل الصهيوني على ارض فلسطين وكانت ارض
بلا شعب
بعض الاغاني بعود عمرها لمئات السنين اذا
مش الاف السنين جزء منها كلمه تحتوي على
كلمات كنعانيه
نبشنا لهذا التراث تقديمه واحيائه واحياءه
لانه فعلا مش موجود احياءه
على المسارح بين اطفالنا حتى يحملوا الجيل
الشاب للاجيال الجاي وعمليا عمال يقول انه
لا الشعب الفلسطيني الشعب اللي عنده مئات
القوالب الغنائيه هذا الشعب ما خلق امبارح
فلسطين هذا الشعب جذوره ضاربه في القدم
على ارض كنعان وقطع ارض
[موسيقى]
نتحدى
تحيه لكل المقاومين بالكلمه باللحن
بالريشه بالقلم هؤلاء الفنانين الذين
ينافحون عن قضيتهم قضيه فلسطين ويقاومون
عنها بفنهم نرحب بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
وبضيوفنا الكرام ايضا يصلنا استقبال من
الناصره دلال ابو امال فنانه والدكتوره في
علوم الدماغ والاعصاب من هانوفر في
المانيا الدكتور بشار شموط والمتخصص في
مجال الارشفه الرقميه للارث الفلسطيني
المسموع والمرئي ومن غزه اميه جحا رسامه
الكاريكاتير اهلا بضيوفنا جميعا لعلنا
نبدا معك دكتوره دلال انت تحملنا دكتوره
في علوم الدماغ وفيزيولوجيا الاعصاب انت
ام زوجه فنانه ذات صوت رائع يحمل بين
نظراته
قضيه فلسطين وينافق عنها من وجهه نظرك ما
اهميه الفن فعلا كاداه للمقاومه وتثبيت
الحق الفلسطيني امام غطرسه الاحتلال
مساء الخير فيروز انا جدا سعيده اللي
موجوده معكم
في هذا البرنامج الراقي وبعد هذا التقرير
الرائع جدا اللي انعمل عن عن الفن ودور
الفن المقاوم في فلسطين طبعا يعني تتقاطع
ادوارنا في هذه الحياه وتتعدد الالقاب لكن
بالنهايه الالقاب هي ما هي الا قبعات
نرتديها لنقوم بادوار لخدمه الناس وعلى
امل ان نتذكر ونرتقي في هذه الحياه
طبعا انت اشرتي الى كوني ايضا دكتوره
وكوني فنانه وفي كلتا الحالتين انا اقوم
بدور من خلاله اتجول في النفس ان كان من
خلال بحث في علوم الدماغ اللي نبحث فيها
عن ذاكرتنا البشريه او من خلال تجولنا في
ازقه فلسطين
محاوله منا لاحياء الذاكره الجمعيه حتى
نحافظ عليها من الاندث بالذات لا لشعب
يقبع تحت الاحتلال طبعا للفن دور عظيم في
الحفاظ على تماسك
الفسيفساء بين ابناء الشعب الواحد
وكشعب فلسطيني يعاني من هذه التجزئات
والتقسيمات نحن في اشد الحاجه لدور الفن
الجمعي الذي يشمل الجميع من خلال من خلال
ادوات بسيطه من خلال تفاصيل لحنيه بسيطه
او تفاصيل جماليه صوريه من خلال لوحات من
خلال تطريز من خلال ماكولات موروثات شعبيه
تساعدنا على لم الشمل
والفتات هذا اللي حاولوا يفسخونا ويجزؤونا
فيه اتحول الى ضيف الكريم دكتور بشاط بشار
عفوا وكلكم يعني كل واحد فيكم قصه جميله
تستحق فعلا ان تروا للمشاهد العربي من
خلال برنامج القصه بقيه انت تنتمي الى
عائله فنيه ايضا دكتور بشار والداكم
الفنان التشكيل التشكيليان
اسماعيل شموط وتمام الاكحل الوالد كما
اشرنا من مؤسسي قسم الفنون في منظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه نتساءل حقيقه الابن
كيف يرى الميراث الذي تركه الوالدان فيما
يخص ربما المقاومه التي قام بها عن على
طريقتهما الخاصه من خلال الفن
مساء الخير وشكرا جزيلا لدعوتي هذا
البرنامج المهم جدا
انا يعني بذكر في طفولتي يعني
الطفولتي كانت في بيروت في صدم الحراك
الوطني والسياسي في في بيروت في سبعينيات
القرن الماضي والوالد والوالده يعني وانا
كنت طفل اعيش في الهواء اللي كنت بتنفسه
كان الوان
فالوالد والوالده يعني طبعا بما انهم
كلاهما مروا في تجربه والتهجير اللوحه
اللي شايفينها سنعود واحده من اعماله اللي
عملها وكان عمره 24 او 23 سنه في عام 54
فهذه كلياتها الاجواء اللي انا ربيت فيها
وطبعا يعني
المهم في الموضوع انه دائما الفن هو يعكس
سيره الحياه وكل شعب كل شعب يعني عنده
ثقافته وفنه والمهم في في هذا
[موسيقى]
عليه ولكن انا بقول يعني عبر مئات السنين
يعني ايام
الحروب الصليبيه لا العثمانيين لا
للانجليزي كلياتنا يعني مرينا في كل
الاحتلالات الغير يعني على فلسطين ولكن
بالنهايه ما زلنا ناكل زيت وزعتر ولسه
فهذا يعني يعطيني امل للمستقبل فعم يعني
بشكل بسيط انه يعني الهويه الوطنيه لا بد
من الحفاظ عليها لانه هذه الهويه الوطنيه
هي تعكس المستقبل تعكس الماضي يعني تفتح
الطريق للامام كلمه مهمه جدا ذكرتها ذكرت
بان الثقافه هي تدوين للتاريخ والفن
اجمالا تدوين للتاريخ وانت اخترت يعني
ارشبت كل ذلك هذا الارشيف تثبيتا لهذا
الحق ساعود اليك دكتور بشار لكن دعني
اتحول ايضا للسيده اميه جحا التي رسومها
يعني
مشهوره ومعروفه لدى القاسي والداني السيده
اميه انت متخصصه في الرياضيات انت معلمه
لكنك اخترتي فن الكاريكاتير اهميه فن
الكاريكاتير بالنسبه لك ايضا من منطقه
كغزه غزه التي تعاني ما تعانيك عده اجزاء
اخرى في فلسطين ايضا كيف ترينها وكيف
يتمثل فنك المقاوم
اهلا بك يا اختي فيروز وبضيوفك الكرام
عبر برنامجك الرائع الذي اتابعه دوما
بالتاكيد فن الكاريكاتير فن هادف وراقي
جدا وهو يعد يعني سلاح قوي جدا في المعركه
ضد المحتل كيف لا ورسوماتنا دوما توضع
عليها العين الصهيونيه تتابع كل ما يرسمه
الفنان الفلسطيني ليس فقط حتى عن القضيه
الفلسطينيه بل يتابع ماذا يرسم عن قضايا
شعوب الاخرى هنالك مواقع تختص فقط باظهار
رسومات الفنانين الفلسطينيين وتحديد
رسومات فنانين الكاريكاتير كون انه فن
يومي فن يتعامل مع الاحداث السياسيه
اليوميه والمتغيره دوما
وبالتالي فن الكاريكاتير لهذه الخصوصيه
التي يتمتع بها لذلك هو يتمتع باهميه
كبيره جدا
فن ساهم بشكل كبير في فضح ممارسات
الاحتلال
فما بالك عندما نكون في وضع يعني في غزه
مثلا تعرضنا الى اربعه او ما يقارب حتى
خمسه حروب متفرقه هذه الحروب عندما
يواجهها الفنان الفلسطيني وفي ظل الضغط
وظل الخوف والقصف الدائم والخوف على
المحيطين حولك هنا تبرز اهميه ان ينافح
الفنان الفلسطيني ويصر على ابراز الوجه
البشع لهذا الاحتلال الذي لا يريد سوى كتم
الصوت الفلسطيني كل فنان فلسطيني كان
يتعرض للمضايقات انا تعرضت على سبيل
المثال اربع مرات لحجم صفحتي الفيسبوك من
خلال بلاغات الاسرائيليين حول
رسوماتي اخرها كان صفحه موثقه
وبالطبع يعني هذا الاتهام ايضا بمعاداه
الساميه وكما كان في التقرير ايضا كان
دوما الفنان الفلسطيني يتهم بهذه التهمه
رغم من حقه الطبيعي والشرعي ان يدافع عن
قضيته بكل الوسائل التي تتاح له هو لا
يعني هو لا يعني انا كفنان ادافع عن قضيه
ليس برصاص بل من خلال ريشه التي يعدها
الاحتلال وكما اعدها والكثيرون يعرفون ذلك
ان الفنان الفلسطيني تعد ايضا ريشته سلاح
وسلاح فتاق ايضا الرصاصه ربما تقتل روحه
ولاديرا ايضا
تقتل فكرا نعم صحيح
سيده دلال سيده اميه اشارت الى نقطه مهمه
جدا في بدايه حديثها تتعلق بمحاربه
ومضايقه الاحتلال للفن الفلسطيني بكل
انواعه انت من ابناء الناصره كيف تجلى لك
ربما هذا النوع من التضييق عليك شخصيا
ربما في ممارسه هذا الفن على جمع هذا
التراث اهميه المشروع الذي انت تقومين
عليه يا ستي ربما ما العقبات التي تعترضكم
ربما في تثبيت الحق الفلسطيني كما ذكرنا
عن طريق الفن من قبل الاحتلال
طبعا يعني التضييقات اللي يواجهها الفنانه
الفلسطيني عامه هي صديقات كبيره في ظل
عالم يعيش بمنظومه طبعا جميعنا يعرف
من يحكمها وما اهدافها
احنا وتحديدا كفنانه فلسطينيه اللي ولدت
في ال 48 كابنه للناصره
نحن نعاني الامرين لانه احنا
عشنا وولدنا في واقع متناقض هذا الواقع
يحثنا على يعني على من ناحيه احنا بدنا
نحافظ على تواصلنا مع هويتنا الجمعيه
هويتنا الكون
الجمعيه مع باقي الشعب الفلسطيني من ناحيه
انت عايشه في واقع فرض فرض عليك انك تحملي
وثائق رسميه لا تمثلك ولا تعبر عن هويتك
واقعنا المتناقي طبعا جبرنا انه نمشي
نحترف المشي بين النقاط زي ما بقولوا
ونحاول قدر الامكان نوصل الرسائل اللي
احنا بدنا نوصلها للحفاظ على
هويتنا وحفاظ على فنه والممارسته وبنفس
الوقت نقدر نحافظ على اولادنا وعلى حياتنا
عن فنك الراقي يعني نود ان نعرف هذا الارث
الفلسطيني والمشروع التي انت قائمه عليه
مشروعي يا ستي ما ماهيته ماذا تريدين منه
مشروع يا ستي هو مشروع بدا من ثمان سنوات
مشروع غنائي يعنى باحياء الموروث
الفلسطيني هذا المشروع
يعني بدا في الاعتناء بالموروث الفلسطيني
لكن لاحقوا ايضا الموروث الشامي موروث
بلاد الشام والعالم العربي لانه احنا كيان
واحد يجمعوا الكثير الكثير من القواسم
المشتركه المشروع بلش من من ثمان سنوات
بدا كدعابي لما توقعتش انها تستمر حتى
اليوم هو مشروع تقود نساء نسوه فقط كل
واحده من مهنتها ومن وظيفتها اتت لتشاركنا
في هذه الذاكره الجمعيه لحتى نستحضر
فلسطين ما قبل النكبه تلك الجلسات اللي
كانت تقام سرا بين النساء ننقلها اليوم
على المسارح في كل العالم
لهذا المشروع صار في عندنا مشروع ابناء
وحده مشروع مشوار سته اللي هو برنامج
اقدمه من خلاله نزور بلدات فلسطين كلها
زيارتنا لكل بلده نحن نلقي التحيه على
الازقه وعلى البلدات القديمه وعلى الاسواق
من خلال الاغنيه من خلال سرد الروايه
بطريقه
ملانه امل ملاني حياه نحن مستمرين في هذه
الحياه وجزء من وظيفتنا كفنانين نظهر
الجمال
والامل للناس اللي عايشه في هذا الواقع
تحاول دكتور بشار دكتور بشار ذكرنا بانك
ايضا تقوم بنوع من المقاومه من خلال ارشبت
هذا الموروث المهم الذي يثبت وجود الانسان
الفلسطيني الاقدم من اي وجود اخر لماذا
توجه الى هذا الموضوع ما اهميته ماذا عن
ابحاثك انت لديك كتاب ايضا في هذا الموضوع
اطلعنا عن ذلك واطلع المشاهد الكريم لو
تكرمت
يعني انا خلفيتي بعرفش يعني يمكن بعضكم
بعرف انه خلفيتي انا جاي من الهندسه
الموسيقيه والهندسه الصوتيه وتسجيل
الانتاج الموسيقي
وبشتغل هون في المانيا من يعني عشرات
السنين او السنين طويله في مجال
الارشفه الصوتيه في شركات يعني داخل
المانيا بعدين في بدات اتساءل يعني احنا
كفلسطينيين يعني الارشيفات الفلسطينيه
يعني اللي تخصنا وين موجوده هل هي في
ايادي فلسطينيه هل ممكن نحافظ عليها
للاجيال القادمه وهم بحسيت انه في مشكله
في يعني عنا ماضي لانه هذه الارشيفات وهذا
الموروث المسموع والمرئي يعني ليس في
ايادي فلسطينيه او جزء كبير منه في
الفلسطينيه جزء جزء موجود في اوروبا في
الشفاه المانيه فرنسيه بريطانيه الاخ ولكن
الجزء الاهم هو
اخذت من قبل
الجيش الاسرائيلي كغنائم حرب تحديدا بعد
اجتياح لبنان في العام 1982 واخذ كميه
هائله جدا من الصور والتسجيلات الصوتيه
والبوسترات
والملصقات يعني والافلام كلها موجود في
الارشيفات العسكريه الاسرائيليه ومغلق
عليها وهذه النقطه مهمه جدا يعني
الارشيفات الاوروبيه مفتوحه ولكن
الارشادات الاسرائيليه مغلق عليها للاسباب
لحتى تحدثنا
ربما من ان انتصارها ام ماذا يعني الخشيه
حقيقه انها تتواجد في يد المحتل في نهايه
الامر الذي يهمه طمس الادله يعني في كل
مجال راينا ذلك
يؤثر في كتابه التاريخ وهذا من هذا
المنطلق يعمل
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على على يعني الهيمنه
على الارشيفات فقط فتح المواد اللي هو مع
اللي في فتحها اما بقيه المواد اللي قد
يعني تؤثر في في او تكرس الروايه
الفلسطينيه طبعا راح يسكرها فهنا في مشكله
هلا دايما في عنا في في الدول الاوروبيه
والغربيه
وفي دول العالم في عنا دائما مؤسسات وطنيه
اللي هي تعمل على الحفاظ على الذاكره
الجمعيه للشعب يعني مثلا في عنا في
بريطانيا
لامريكا
حتى في اسرائيل في العشيه في الوطني
الاسرائيلي لكن عن الطرف الفلسطيني يعني
ما في فش مؤسسه وطنيه او دوليه او تابعه
للدوله اللي هي تعمل على الحفاظ بشكل كبير
واساسي طبعا في افكار وفي
مبادرات ولكن ما في اشي يعني ما فيش شيء
منسق فمن هون اجت الفكره انه يعني خلينا
نحاول كل هالمؤسسات اللي عم بتبادر بشكل
شخصي او فردي زي ما تفضلتي ذكرتي قبل
شوية الملصقات اللي اللي قام عليه شخص
يعني حتى اجنبي في امريكا يعني هذه كلها
مبادرات فرديه او شخصيه لكن لا بد من ربط
هذه المبادرات مع بعض بحيث انه نقدر نحافظ
عليها عن طريق الرقمنه عن طريق التقنيات
الحديثه للاجيال القادمه لانه انا بحتفظ
بالشغله مش ملكيه
الشعب كله
وانا يعني جدا سعيد انه في مبادرات جديده
ومقدرات يعني كتير مهمه
وكمان سعيد جدا لانه الجيل الشباب يعني بس
حاضر في جامعات او يعني اتحدث مع الشباب
يعني اتفاجئ بشكل ايجابي انه في عندهم
اهتمام بالفعل انه هذه الثقافه او هذا
الارث انه موجود يعني في اجدادنا عملوا
ارث يعني مش زي ما
ايضا موجود بالفعل لدى هؤلاء الشباب اتحول
مره اخرى للسيده اميه جحا يعني
كما ذكرنا هو فن راقي كيف ترين تاثيره على
المجتمع في غزه على المجتمع الفلسطيني
اجمالا كيفيه التفاعل مع هل ترينه ربما
رسومات عابره تنسى ام انها عابره للازمان
والاجيال ايضا ولنا ربما في
ناجي العلي شاهدا ومثالا على ذلك
نعم اريد ان اقول ان الشعب الغزي تحديدا
شعب مثقف جدا
وثقافته العاليه هذه جعلته ايضا ملتصقا
بفن الكاريكاتير وفمه لهذا الفن بذكاء
وبنقد ايضا نقد بناء طبعا
وبالتالي التفاعل الجماهيري مع فن
الكاريكاتير تفاعل راقي جدا جدا من
المظاهر لهذا التفاعل انه حتى ظهر الكثير
من فنانين الكاريكاتير فيما بعد في غزه
تحديدا ربما الاحداث التي مر بها القطاع
وتوالي الحروب ودوما يكون يعني القطاع
مرصود من قبل الاحتلال كونه يعني شعب
يتمسك بالمقاومه ويحتضن المقاومه كل هذه
الامور جعلت هنالك نوع من التحدي ما بين
الفنان الفلسطيني وبين المحتل الذي يريد
طمس الحقيقه يريد ان يكبل الفنان
الفلسطيني ولا يظهر فنه وابداعه يقوم
بقمعه سواء اتهامه بالساميه او من خلال
اغلاق صفحاتي التواصل الاجتماعي وتلك
النافذه التي يطيل من خلالها على العالم
ليرى العالم الحقيقه
الاكثر مصداقيه من روايه الاحتلال
وبالتالي كان هنالك التحدي الواضح من خلال
الفنان الفلسطيني يتحدى كل الصعاب ينشر
اغلقت صفحه يفتح صفحه اخرى يرسم حتى بكل
اللغات حاليا اصبحوا هنالك تفاعل ايضا
وامتداد غربي في الخارج لنا هنالك من ياخذ
رسوماتنا وينشرها في معارض
في بلاد اوروبا كل هذا يساهم في نشر
التعاطف ايضا مع القضيه الفلسطينيه وايضاح
الروايه الصحيحه للشعب الفلسطيني كل يعني
رسم لك سيده اميه جحا يحمل رساله لكن في
كل رسم كاريكاتير يعني يتردد توقيعك
وبصمتك التي يعرفها الجميع وهي مفتاح
العوده يعني ما الرساله باعتقادك الابلغ
ربما من هذا التوقيع والى اي مدى تفهم كما
ذكرتي وهي عابره للغات ايضا هذا المفتاح
يعني يفهمه القاصي والداني ايا كانت اللغه
ربما التي يتحدثوها
اردته ان يبقى اشاره الى اننا لن نتخلى عن
قضيتنا الفلسطينيه ولن نتخلى عن ارضنا
وحقنا في ارضنا
ربما كان ميلاد هذا المفتاح بعد حادثه
هامه جدا في حياتي عندما فقدت زوجي شهيدا
في عام 2003 بعد هذه الحادثه تواصل معي
واتصل بي دكتور يهودي يعمل في احدى
الجامعات في الجامعات الاحتلال وكان ضليعا
باللغه العربيه وقال لي بالحرف الواحد
ماذا استفدتي من كل الرسوماتك ها هو زوجك
قد استشهد وانت الان لن ترسمي ولن تفعلي
اي شيء انت الان ارمل انت الان ام لطفل
يتيمه
ماذا فعلت المقاومه انت فقدت الان زوجك
نحن الاحق بهذا الوطن انظري الى عائله
فلان مثلا عائله المصري العدل على انهم
عائدون من مصر عائله الشامي جاؤوا من بلاد
الشام يعني يريد ان يقول بانه ليس لكم
اصول وجذور انتم كفلسطينيين
من بعد هذا الاتصال الذي رددت عليه قلت له
بان يعني هذا المفتاح جاء هذا المفتاح بعد
ذلك مذيلا في كل رسومات افخر بهذا المفتاح
انا انا يعني لم يكن لم يحتفظ اجدادي
بمفتاح
لابقى اتمسك به فجعلت هذا المفتاح رمزا
لكل فلسطيني
باذن الله عائدون الى ترابنا من النهر الى
البحر باذن الله اعود اليك دلال السيده
اميه اشارت الى نقطه انه يجب لهذا الفن
فعلا ان يكون عابرا للجغرافيا ايضا يعني
اهميه ان يكون الفنان ربما متواصل مع
المحيط الخارجي للتعريف بقضيته انت بالذات
كانت لك صولات وجولات سواء في العالم
العربي في مهرجانات عديده وحتى في
الولايات المتحده في الغرب كيف رايت
التفاعل بالفعل مع فنك الذي يحمل في طي
اته يعني ابلغ رساله متعلقه بمقاومه
الاحتلال
طبعا في جولاتي
احمل رساله انه الفن هو اولا اولا انها
فلسطين هي ليست قضيه قوميه فحسب انما
القضيه انسانيه اولا وقبل اي شيء هي قضيه
تعني كل انسان في هذا العالم وليس فقط
العرب ففي جولاتي احاول ان اشدد على هذا
الجانب من خلال المشروع يا ستي وعدد من
المشاريع الاخرى ايضا المشروع الصوفي الذي
اقوم فيه في التغني في حب الله وفي
التحديث عن القواسم المشتركه بيننا جميعا
وفي نهايه انا اصلي لغزه مع الجمهور في
هذا الحفل نحن هنا نجذب الجمهور العربي
والغربي لكي يتعامل مع قضيه فلسطين كقضيه
انسانيه اولا وقبل اي شيء
كما نعلم وحتى في علوم الاعصاب والدماغ
بصفه دكتوره في هذا المجال اليوم تم اثبات
ان الغناء والفنون عامه فيها الكثير من
الشفاء اذا استخدمت كاداه من اجل توعيه
الناس
من فطرتهن من خلال الصوت الجميل احنا
بنسمع التراتيل والاناشيد والتلاوات هي
تخترق وجداننا بشكل افضل بشكل اعمق هي
تساهم في تعزيز وتقويه النفس وتعزيز الصله
هاي واللحمه بين الناس وبمشروع يا ستي
احنا بدانا بمشروع من خلال عشر سيدات
لرفقوني مع الكثير من الحرج والخوف والحذر
لانه مش فاهماتهن لوين دخلات اليوم احنا
تجاوزنا المئه وخمسين عرض في فلسطين
والعالم
ويحوي هذا المشروع اكثر من 2500 امراه
ليست فقط فلسطينيه انما عربيه
واجنبيه تساعدنا وهي جزء من مشروع يا ستي
نغني جميعا الموروث الفلسطيني الى جانب
الموروث العربي وهذا الجميل يعني كل
فلسطيني يحمل مشروعا الدكتور بشار لديه
مشروعه ايضا الخاص بالحفاظ على هذا
الموروث لديك كتاب نشرته بالالمانيه
ترجمته للغه العربيه يحمل عنوان الارثه
الفلسطيني المرئي والمسموع نشاته وتشتته
والحفاظ الرقمي عليه حدثنا عن كيفيه
الحفاظ الرقمي عليه باعتقادي في اي اتجاه
يجدر ربما التحرك وقلت بانه يجب تظافر
الجهود
صحيح يعني انا هلا
الرقم هذا يعني تقنيه الرقم انا لها دور
اساسي في الوضع الفلسطيني يعني
المحتل الاسرائيلي بحاول يشتت او يفتت
هالشعب الفلسطيني ويعني في اجزاء معينه في
الضفه الغربيه في 48 في غزه في الشتات في
لبنان في في الخارج فالرقمنا عمليا يعني
تكون عابره للحدود وبالتالي ممكن للباحث
الفلسطيني او للفنان الفلسطيني سواء
متواجد في في المخيمات في لبنان في غزه في
اي مكان انه يوصل عن طريق التقنيه الرقميه
للمواد اللي عم بدور عليها فمن هون اهميه
الرقميه يعني الدور مميز في الوضع
الفلسطيني بشكل عام
الشغله الثانيه اللي عم بتنتج يعني عم
تطلع معنا حديثا انه هي
الذكاء الصناعي يعني
[موسيقى]
هذه قضيه جدا مهمه في في مستقبل الارشفاء
يعني مثلا
الواحد ممكن يكون عم ببحث عن ماده معينه
فمش عارف وين يلاقيها ولكن الذكاء
الاصطناعي ممكن يساعده انه
تكنولوجيا فعلا بامكانها ان تكون في خدمه
مثل هذا المشروع لتثبيت الحق كما ذكرنا
الدكتور بشار الوقت للاسف يعني بدا ليس
يعمل في صالحنا سيده اميه يعني في عجاله
لو تكرمت اشرت الى نقطه
التكنولوجيا الرقميه واشار اليها ايضا
دكتور بشار هناك ثوره الان تكنولوجيه كيف
يمكن ربما الاستفاده منها في ربما كسر
الحدود الجغرافيه وايصال فنك وفن الجميع
الذين يعانون من الحصار في غزه الى العالم
باختصار لو تكرمت
نعم بالتاكيد لها دور كبير جدا يكفي ان
الفنان الفلسطيني لم يعد محصورا فقط
بالصحيفه الورقيه التي باتت الان
بالانتصار عالم الورق ولكن هذه الثوره
الرقميه ومواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ساهمت
ايضا في ابراز فنانين لم يتعاملوا مع صحف
رسميه وبالتالي ساعه ماساهمت في اثراء
الفن الفلسطيني والرساله الفلسطينيه
الفنيه وانتشارها بشكل كبير جدا والتواصل
ما بين الشعوب وكسر الحواجز لتصل القضيه
الفلسطينيه الى كل بقاع العالم واظهار
الحقيقه
الواضحه التي يريد الاحتلال طمسها بكل
الوسائل اشكركم جزيل الشكر السيده اميه
جحاره الكاريكاتير من غزه كما اشكر جزيل
الشكر دكتور بشار شرموط المتخصص في مجال
الارشفه الرقميه للارسل الفلسطينيه
المسموع والمرء من هانوفر في المانيا
وقبل ان اشكر دلال ابو امنه الفنانه
والدكتوره في علوم الدماغ والاعصاب نود ان
نختم معك بصوتك الجميل والرائع وكلمات عن
الفن المقاومه الفلسطيني تلامس الوجدان
وجدان الاحرار حول العالم
ساسمعكم قصيده للشاعر الفلسطيني الراحل
عصام العباسي
تتغنى في حب هذه البلاد
[موسيقى]
تيرارارارا
بلادي كم احبك
[موسيقى]
يا بلادي فيك اروع وما
تغنى
فؤادي
بلادي
كم احبك
يا
بلادي فيك
اروع وما تغناه
فؤادي بلادي
[موسيقى]
في
رجوعك في
جباه في تلاوه
لكي هو الوهاد انت
جهري انت
همسي في اقت
وابتعادي بلا
[موسيقى]
دي
بلادي الله الله يا دلال يعني هذا يعني
كلمات في حب البلاد وكيف ان كانت البلاد
فلسطين وما ادراك ما فلسطين اشكركم جزيل
الشكر ختام حلقتنا الممتعه هذه كل التوفيق
لكم في هذا ايصال هذا الفن المقاوم
للعالم اجمع في رساله انسانيه نبيله ختام
حلقتنا مشاهدينا الكرام برنامج القصه بقي
نعود ونلقاكم باذن الله مع بقيه بقصه
جديده السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]